back in the corner McDavid skates free of burrows
now a wrist shot that cron is able to find and
still looking for it as it deflected away McDavid
for Evan buard back to him the onetime ripped
wide as the Oilers really pouring it on here early
Hyman the drop pass a shot by McLoud and he scores
the Oilers all over the Sharks on the first
shift and Ryan McLoud makes it one- nothing
Ryan Nan Hopkins goes off the ice with all the
pressure and here comes McLoud McLoud jumps in
he is wide open good shot beats Magnus Crona
on the wide side but it's all because a guy
was smart on the change one of the things that
the coaches for the Sharks want their guys to
do is try to shut down down for here's Evander
Kane the former shark off to a good start with
13 goals and 23 points for this Oilers team
that has six 30 point scores Crona gobbling
up the wrist shot and duclair able to work it out
over the line and up for Fabian zedin zedin with
a wrist shot he fan got the second one away and
Stewart Skinner got his blocker up on it number
25 tridle clicks it out to Cody now nurse the
one-time cor of the save rebound back to the
Oilers certainly settled things down a little bit
after that first minute when the Oilers got their
goal echol a blast and Crona with the save now
Bailey all the way back in the corner for the
Sharks they'll work it ahead for Burrows and
now barabanov little lacad isical to that Puck
and it was Swept Away by nurse and they scor four
off the turnover it's Hyman and it's two nothing
oers you cannot turn the puck over at the
offensive blue line that gives you or gives
the ERS the transition ability although a really
good play made by Darnell Nur on that but you have
to make sure when you're approaching the line
approach with speed and put the puck behind the
d man instead it goes the other way and that's the
last guy you want to have have it making the pass
near your net Conor mcav with Zack Heyman now
Hamlin gives it for Darnell nurse shot turned
aside with a stick by Magnus brona picked up
by cnan who fires the flex off an Oiler comes
right back to C now Ruda tees it up saved by
Skinner cleared from the front of the net by
the ERS but not out a tremendous opportunity for
his first head coaching job interestingly coming
out of the New York Rangers organization
is game got the stop or McDavid rather the
Rangers made a coaching change in the off seon
hurdle recovering it back in the corner of the
oiler Zone and it's taken away by dry Sidle
best chance of the game there and now hurdle
back in business again he's got eckan and zinaa
and Ferraro and it's stopped by Skinner Mario
Ferraro with a great a chance in the slot and
Stuart Skinner came up big as Fogle can't get
past shark defense there's a shot by the owners
that deflex into the corner echol sending it back
the other way it's rimmed around by Ernie now
buard works it up the wing dry Sidle to Conor
Brown to eom tipped in front of the net on the
backand By Ernie and the Oilers buzzing here
on this ship Adam Ernie scoots behind the net
past eckan works it to atol the broken stick
that everybody's trying to navigate G on the ice
here's a chance for the Oilers and a good back
check by Carpenter broke up the chance for Echo
Brown has sported hole this year for the Oilers
makes it to the blue line now at home again H
pivot give it and they score buard the onetime
a huge amount of traffic in front of the shark
net it is three nothing Oilers here at the Shark
Tank and I don't think Magnus see this but it's
again not able to kill plays the sharks have been
trying for it and trying for it Magnus croner
just looking at 57 that's all he's looking at
he's looking at James Hamlin who fides a great
screen CL starting things with the first go of
this game he now has four goals Five Points
ran McLoud does in his last three games he's
heating up chance in front here for dry cidal and
he scores didn't look like he had enough room but
it's Leon brydle it's 4 nothing here in the first
ridle is an amazing player he absolutely a big
man who goes a net he's got terrific hands very
strong on a stick there what a nice pass really
when you look at that pass coming out of the
corner by Warren Fogle good pass and Leon a big
body that once he gets to going downhill tough
to knock off the clock he fights off the check
marked out front is Ruda but gramlin couldn't get
him the pass now zland with the puck and now huk
and that one's kicked out by Skinner he waits
Waits now he's jumping in in this opportunity
he sees the plate go to WS the oers big addition
ahead of last year's tra deadline Matias EO great
hurdle eckan rebound off the post by sadena nurse
up on the right point now switching up to newon
Hopkins hman taken to the boards by Burrows
Puck still belongs to the oers CC this one
trickles through and in Zack hman got a piece it
went through the five hole and it's five nothing
Edmonson movement the Sharks not able to stop the
play not able to stop the offensive push and this
one bounces bounces and then can get deflected as
well so it goes off a one two guys bounces three
guys and maybe four guys with Hyman Fogle and
now McLoud to dry Sidle Le on dry Sidle skates
through and King in with a nice save as dry Sidle
used his power to get that puck to the net Conor
McDavid just one point so far and his fans on his
shot attempt he flip it back for de into the slot
tip play there it was tipped by kulak on net saved
by Kenan that one blocked by xland and to the net
Sav by Kenan Fogle dle and Kenan got the club up
on that even see it and then he has to deal with
Leon Tri settle what an excellent push across
and there is number 71 Ryan McLoud second round
draft picked back in 2018 by the Oilers he's had
himself quite a month and there's McDavid hitting
the goal post right by the net P just bounc in oh
oh yeah he'd be looking at that one wondering how
he did not put that in goes to the far post puck
just gets by Henry run sharks in the scrap Bailey
over the line for the sharks with barabanov seeing
all kinds of different line combinations in this
game for the San Jose Sharks as David quins trying
to find something and there's a shot off the bar
by Carpenter hurdle sends it across hoop and shot
off the glove of Skinner wrap around by hurle and
Skinner protecting that side of the net comes up
with the save held on to a little bit longer than
you probably liked as a coach but it kept working
with it kept staying with it then hopin gets that
chance to the net I love that hurdle jumps on
it too hurdle slides behind the net And Then
There It Is it goes right onto his stick he just
appear and the Oilers will flip it down the ice
and they will indeed get a shut out from Stuart
Skinner this game was decided in the first period